a volcano in Southwestern Iceland has
erupted for a third time since December
the eruption began at 6:00 a.m. local
time soon after an intense burst of
seismic activity now Jets of lava
rocketed into the sky triggering an
evacuation of the Blue Lagoon Spa one of
the island nation's biggest tourist
attractions Icelandic meteorological
office said that lava was flowing to the
west and there's no immediate threat to
a major power plant in the area
so this eruption is similar to the
December 18th eruption it's in the same
general area it's further from grindavik
uh compared to the 14th of uh January
but the problem here is the lava is
Flowing towards West and it flowed over
the road already uh leading to grenvik
and it's now heading towards um the hot
water pipes in the area the lava
actually FL flowed over the road and uh
it's uh heading towards the hot water
pipes supplying uh hot water to the
general Reon area so uh that's that's
serious news around theeni power plant
um dkes were already in place but the
problem is of course there are hot water
pipes leading from the power plant to
the to the users and um those pipes are
in in great danger
now
well it's it's a bit early to say if if
the eruption is already veining but the
LA the progress of the lava front has
been really rapid this time it of course
also depends on the topography in the
area and it's it's quite rapid
progress